the next generation of gaming has
arrived and its name is the Atari 2600
this new state-of-the-art console brings
the thrills of your local arcade right
into your living room boasting 128 bytes
of RAM and a 1.9 megahertz processor the
Atari 2600 offers an experience of
unparalleled player immersion ever
wondered what it'd be like to navigate
interstellar space
I have played space work and I can
assure you that man's final frontier is
nothing short of heart-stopping
jaw-dropping exhilaration raise the
stakes and compete with friends players
will lose themselves in a virtual world
just teeming with excitement paddles are
also available but my personal favorite
is the joystick I just can't get enough
of it goodbye pong is stone-age call I'd
like to play some table tennis let us
know your favorite retro gadgets in the
comments and please subscribe to our
Channel